es el último día de la Cumbre del g7 en
Japón el presidente ucraniano voló de
mercedesky se llevó los reflectores en
Hiroshima y en el último día se encontró
con el Primer Ministro japonés
fumikohida agradeció la presencia de
selensky y subrayó el apoyo del grupo
con kiev estamos comprometidos con
Ucrania y estamos con ellos primero para
devolver la paz estamos decididos a
hacerlo
además de reunirse con el premiere
japonés se lensky se reunió con Los
jefes de estado de Canadá Francia y
Estados Unidos el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden anunció un nuevo
paquete de ayuda militar a Ucrania con
un valor de más de 300 millones de
dólares
hoy voy a anunciar el siguiente tramo de
la ayuda estadounidense a la seguridad
de Ucrania un paquete que incluye
munición artillería y vehículos
blindados para reforzar las capacidades
de Ucrania en el campo de batalla
otro de los temas que lideraron la
agenda en las reuniones fue el papel de
china en la economía mundial y en su rol
de mediador en la guerra en Ucrania el
Primer Ministro británico Richie sunak
calificó al gigante asiático como el
reto más grande de nuestros tiempos
el g7 también demostró unidad de
proposito respecto a China china plantea
el mayor desafío a la seguridad y
prosperidad mundiales de nuestra era el
grupo de los siete finalizó su ciclo de
reuniones anuales demostrando Unión en
su política exterior como bloque pero
avivando las tensiones con China